[Music]
are you guys aware
of the rolex wearing
diamond ring wearing oh thank god yes
kiss stealing oh my greenland oh my god
limousine writing jet flying son of a
gun
who who is it
rick flair
nature boy dude
so he just had his last match this past
sunday
at the tender age of 70 [ __ ] four
years old wow
what the [ __ ] he retires in 2013 i
believe dad's like my dad's age yeah bro
then how the [ __ ] is he still moving
dude because he's the name barely but he
but but it's one of those weird things
where because you know professional
wrestling there's so much going on like
to sell moves and [ __ ] like you know you
if i like i can grab anthony's head and
then i'm like punching my own hand and
then yeah anthony's like god damn yeah
he's gotta sell it you gotta set like so
bart punches me in the face like this
you gotta like you gotta sell that's a
good sell this is my favorite one
that was so good
i love that [ __ ]
i love that [ __ ] bro my favorite i
[ __ ] gotta give yourself whiplash a
little bit either but when you're a kid
you don't know they're selling it so
you're just actually pile driving your
friend through a [ __ ] dining room
table and then you're like man he's
really not good at selling this
um so yeah he he um
he so he leaves the wwe right like this
is like 2013.
he fights i believe it was shawn
michael's hbk in his last match
and then
um
he's supposed to be retired after that
as a wrestlemania by the way at
wrestlemania yeah and then there's this
really funny part too during that which
i just got caught up on all this to host
the show but but um i forgot about this
there's a part where um
ric flair is basically like he's like
the idea is that if he loses this match
that he has to retire forever forever
and so shawn michaels is about like has
him on the ropes and [ __ ] and then he's
tuning up the band bro yeah yeah yeah
he's tuning up and then um rick rick
flair is basically like come on do it
finish me like finish me put me on my
misery son of a [ __ ] and then sean
michael is about to do his like [ __ ]
sweet chin music thing and he's like
he's like i'm sorry i love you and then
he [ __ ] kicks him in the face yeah
but he also slaps his eye
it's so incredible and it was like no
and then yeah obviously rick flair cried
but then here we are like years and
years later he's 74 years old he gets
with this promotion company that's like
really well known um in in wrestling and
they're doing the last match and then
it's it's caused like kind of an uproar
in the wrestling community because
people like is he too old for this [ __ ]
is he being taken advantage of right
right because he's like kind of an
alcoholic and he's like had money issues
and like he's well known as being like
kind of a he it didn't go so well for
him like with the money stuff damn so he
needed this for his personal real life
he claims he doesn't because he does
like
um what's what's that version of only
fans but for hollywood people buy no not
fiverr um
i know what you're talking about where
they do the shout outs
[ __ ] dante does this
cameo
so yeah which we're gonna start doing
soon but yeah because we need it it's a
recession as the rug boys so he he does
like he claims that he can subsidize a
lot of his income with that stuff um but
then he's doing this wrestling match and
watching this you guys just tell me what
you think because i don't want to lead
the witness we just need a gofundme for
him huh we need to go find him
why is his walkout so tired because
that's how he he what he does the oh
because that's swag walk yeah that's his
swag oh i thought he was coming out like
he needed a [ __ ] crutches or
something
he's still kind of thick though nature
boy he's walking extra slow
that robe looks a little too big for him
it looks like he's out of breath taking
that robe off
oh yeah he's got some snap to his hand
though yeah that that's his chop that's
his but he only got one hand how come
his other he
no he sold it though dude he that's a
backdrop have you ever ever had a
backdrop with your chest dude he [ __ ]
stepped on his hand
yeah see that hurts that much what an
honor must be to be that guy oh yeah jay
lethal he's just slapping his tits
around dude
that will still buff as [ __ ] for old man
right he looks like [ __ ] though man
oh it looks pretty rough oh she's
bleeding yeah damn he can't afford to
lose any more blood no
he needs all the blood he can get
why does he look so old so did ric flair
die oh no he hits him with the figure
four dude jeff jarrett looks great
though jeff jack looks really good is he
still doing the guitar thing how could
him give him his leg is he that
damn is ric flair actually wincing and
paying in real life but if rick that
undertaker
yeah the f was a big [ __ ] dude
he's like 6'5 though no i think he's
like six like six nine or something
everybody's paying respects red heart
was there yeah holy [ __ ] look at this
[ __ ] bloody ass wig i know right damn
they all came so that's the end of it
but yeah damn
i don't know what do you guys think man
you know
have you seen this 30 for 30. yeah dude
it's [ __ ] incredible it's crazy like
that guy isn't his life he gets married
and then the the same night that he gets
married he like leaves and goes and
[ __ ]
you
hookers
can't stop so wild can't stop this
sounds like an interesting warrior it's
like i got married and he's like i
realized he's like yeah i realized like
like a couple hours in i was like yeah
this isn't for me and then he just goes
so does he get a divorce though yeah
[ __ ] yeah he got the worst
did he win that match
he did win that match yeah
yeah i think that's [ __ ] awesome yeah
yeah
if he's down i mean he's been freaking
doing that forever right it probably
looks a lot worse to us yeah if he
doesn't leave like hurt or like
permanently injured i think that's fine
yeah
like you got to [ __ ]
even uh
at the end of the day i think when you
can be
in that space there's so much glory to
be on a stage like that you know what i
mean like let's hit that age you can
tell he loves it
[ __ ] fans just cheering the lights
he's being celebrated too which is dope
yeah it's like nobody's nobody's ragging
on him he's a legend so my question is
when do you think his last match is
going to be i don't know and probably
next year
honestly because that's what everyone's
thinking like it's like
is he really done i mean if that's how
you want to go out right i mean
it's not even just ric flair though it's
like you see it in like other athletes
in general it's like they they take some
time off but then they get addicted to
the glory like that and like robert
parish robert to be honest i want to see
this more i want to see the like 1965
olympics like 100 meter swim winner and
then go in the pool with michael phelps
actually see that guy drown let's see
what happens well i think there's a i
think it's a good idea he's in a
wheelchair and they shove him in the
water
[Laughter]
a showmanship to this right yeah yeah
the showmanship gets to like lend itself
to the narrative of his legend no they
give a walk out he goes like where's
where's my goggles yeah like he gets to
do the whole thing
walk out pull the whole thing off in the
water now
michael phelps is purposefully swimming
slow he keeps asking i want to see ric
flair even in a wheelchair on stage
[ __ ] rolling up to his opponent
slapping him and then they have to sell
that
he does the back shot he like [ __ ]
rolls up there was a couple of moments
during this match too where he did that
they did that like that bomb and brick
floyd didn't even move
[Laughter]
he all started hooking up yeah and like
and like i remember undertaker's seeing
that you can see undertaker just
watching this being like are you [ __ ]
kidding me okay
pretty funny i guess you are gonna have
that but he's gonna be next undertaker
yeah do you think he'll do it he's on
his last limbs oh no he's done he
retired uh he retired like three years
that's the question then it's like did
is this really what rick flair wanted to
do or was he like had no choice like
that is the quest that is the
controversy and that's what people are
wondering and
if he had no choice
and he still had the option to be able
to do this in a place of no choice
that's pretty sick that's true you know
what i mean it's like [ __ ] dude like i'm
out of money oh i could still get out
there and do this and it's like
legendary man i wanted to see you do
america's best dance corner 75. this was
his last if i'm treated like that sure
right everybody else
bigging me up wait that's the one with
uh yeah shawn michaels so this is this
is that moment
dude shot michaels
heartbreak kid you know rick flair is
like no just finish me already when was
this early 2000's he's like come on you
son of a [ __ ]
that's the dagger dude this is all about
the stories huh yeah dude it's all about
the story i've been watching it with the
wrong lens as oh
and he kissed him on the floor how old
do you think ric flair was here like in
his 60s or something yeah yeah yeah so
he was still rolling well if he was 74
this is 2013.
nine years ago he was a lot older than i
thought back when even when he was in
his prime yeah i know he was that old
the fact that he's like 65 and taking a
[ __ ] sidekick to the chin like that
doesn't matter
he's almost 16. dude how old was the
dude that we wrestled with 70s right 60
or 70 yeah because he was [ __ ]
energetic man you wrestled with a 60
yeah we took a wrestling lesson like
professional wrestling lesson with this
guy mr wonderful
yeah really for jk video or mr fantastic
it sounds like these delusional [ __ ]
jumped a guy in a parking lot and like
we yeah we did a arrest this guy [ __ ]
just picked me up watch look it up look
up jk and then wrestling jk adventures
wrestling this guy just picked up like
nothing
me and ryan just laughed because when
you said mr fantastic that's like a
dancer
oh yeah yeah wait how how how much did
you ate during that time probably close
to 200 pounds he just picked me up like
nothing yo i'm getting a lot of and he
[ __ ] whacked me in my chest [ __ ]
just kidding films wrestling jk okay jk
adventures type in just kidding films
and then wrestling jk films wrestling
got to do some cool ass [ __ ] locked due
to elder abuse yeah two asians get beat
up is the title oh that's yeah yeah yeah
yeah so it's not we didn't jump an old
man
dude this guy was [ __ ] strong look at
this guy
[Laughter]
he was tough dude he's in a wedding
singer too he's in all kinds of movies
yeah he's in weddings yeah he's in
wedding singer he's um he's the guy at
the end yeah where uh the dude is gonna
rush towards adam sandler and he goes on
my watch or whatever yeah that's that oh
he's the guy who like helps like block
him in the plane yeah yeah he has to
learn how to break watch go go uh fast
forward just like the beginning parts
there's like parts where he's like
whacking us with chairs and [ __ ] oh is
this a dude whose mustache is like this
yeah yeah yeah
holy [ __ ]
dude i was i had a lot more respect for
the wrestling after this cuz i was like
this is really it's like a true athletic
endeavor most of it is just for like
theater but i'm like the amount amount
of athleticism you need is crazy and the
pain and the pain too the [ __ ] i need to
be able to improvise on a spot like that
yeah like these guys are throwing each
other around they have to like make [ __ ]
up it's at the end bart was it oh you
got hit with a chair i think so i forgot
oh [ __ ] way this guy
i'll try to steal that chair
[ __ ]
bend over oh [ __ ] you know these videos
bart's ass is not as big as this no not
even the [ __ ] way not juicy
oh
did that hurt yeah i did so it was a
real chair yeah but he he didn't go as
hard but they're all wheelchairs and
wrestling but that's that's the thing i
always try to figure out like is there a
way to take a chair hit to the face
without it hurting no it hurts all of it
so when he was showing us like the one
he did like a chestnut boom that should
hurt when you do that you're making sure
the guy that bought a ticket at the far
corner is getting his money's worth so
he's like wow it's [ __ ] hard as [ __ ]
is this the same guy
yeah same dude dude we hired him for a
[ __ ] red food lmf video no way oh
yeah he plays a cop yeah yeah he always
plays cops yeah yeah that's so tight
holy [ __ ] just to say it again logan
paul's [ __ ] frog splash fire oh bro
oh my god yeah from the from the rope
crazy yeah we should start breaking down
wrestling videos grabs the [ __ ]
little pad throws it at the chick's face
first i was like yo jk reacts to wwe
well done man i love wwe it's [ __ ]
hilarious i love it too i also have a
respect for it that i didn't i don't
remember having as a kid bart's trying
to leave her go ahead mark finish me you
son of a [ __ ] yeah finish me off
i'm sorry
[Music]
[Music]
you